getraut hat wir schauen später wieder
vorbei
doch die ganz großen in der szene das
sind die unbekannten das heißt berühmt
sind sie schauen aber nur ihre werke
ihre identität wollen sie nicht
preisgeben lieber ein mysterium bleiben
und sich den verlockungen des
kunstmarkts wenigstens teilweise
entziehen denn subkultur verpflichtet
banksy etwa der übervater seit 20 jahren
ist er inkognito unterwegs man weiß nur
dass er aus brüssel stand
wir warten das phantom um ein interview
vergeblich
blum aus bologna auch er ein
international anerkannter
street-art-künstler der anonym bleiben
will
kein interview möglich
[Applaus]
und schließlich
barbara
über deren identität ganz deutschland
rätselt sie konnten wir immerhin im chat
befragen
barbara blue und banksy sie sind gerade
künstler die zum zivilen ungehorsam
aufrufen
[Musik]
macy's kommentare sind ironisch und
subversiv
[Musik]
kritisieren die flüchtlingspolitik wie
jüngst in paris
die hatte sein wappentier aus dem
untergrund ist allgegenwärtig
bestand hat diese kunst nicht auch
banksy es werden übermalt seine rate ist
auch im ausland aktiv 2007 an der mauer
im westjordanland wo banksy klar
stellung bezieht
[Musik]
gemeinsam mit banksy war blut und
palästina ein künstler der die streetart
auf faszinierende weise in videokunst
überführt
[Musik]
blue kommt aus der autonomen szene
überflussgesellschaft und
kapitalismuskritik sind seine themen
es geht ums fressen und gefressen werden
[Musik]
häufig gemalt an abbruchhäusern sind
auch bloß bilder flüchtig verschwinden
spätestens bei der nächsten fassaden
renovation das ist teil seines konzepts
doch das sehen nicht alle so 2016 wurden
sieben großformatige gemälde von blue
von den wänden abgetragen fachmännisch
restauriert und in einer street art
ausstellung in bologna präsentiert der
kurator wollte die werke für die
nachwelt erhalten allerdings ohne zuvor
die zustimmung des künstlers einzuholen
blue war dermaßen wütend dass er in
einer öffentlichen aktion alle seine
gemälde in bologna über mal ließ
[Musik]
street art ist für die straße gemacht
und sie muss dort bleiben sagen die
künstler
denn wer sie von dort entfernt spielt
ihrer kommerzialisierung in die hände
das musste banksy vielfach erfahren sein
bild sklavenarbeit das in einem vorort
von london hin wurde eines nachts von
unbekannten entfernt es tauchte in einem
auktionskatalog in florida auf für ein
startgebot von einer halben million
dollar
[Musik]
die bewohner des quartiers protestierten
das gemälde sklavenarbeit ist eine
freche kritik am kapitalismus dass es in
miami an einer auktion verkauft werden
soll läuft völlig der intention zu
wieder mit welcher es entstanden ist
die auktion wurde tatsächlich gestoppt
das bild kam zurück nach england wo es
am ende doch versteigert wurde
für 900.000 pfund street art soll banksy
gesagt haben ist kostenlose kunst für
jedermann
die zum denken anregt ganz in diesem
sinne handelt barbara
die auch schon der deutsche bank sie
genannt wurde
[Musik]
wir interviewten barbara via facebook
sie blieb dabei anonym
selbstverständlich
das kleben von botschaften im
öffentlichen raum ist meine methode mich
in den gesellschaftlichen diskurs
einzubringen
ich entdecke oft rassistische
sexistische oder diskriminierende
schmierereien und möchte das nicht
unkommentiert lassen
bis jetzt hat sich noch kein museum oder
kunsthändler für barbara interessiert
ihre kunst ist wohl zu vergänglich
bereits in meiner auswahl des materials
papier ist ein ja zur vergänglichkeit
enthalten vergänglichkeit ist ein fester
bestandteil von street ort ich finde es
sehr reizvoll dass eine arbeit nur für
wenige tage stunden oder sogar minuten
auf der straße zu sehen ist
von jeder aktion macht barbara ein foto
und postet es auf facebook und instagram
wo ihr hunderttausende folgen
so wie sich die öffentlichkeit ins netz
verlagert bewegt sich auch die street
art zunehmend in den sozialen medien
die sozialen medien sind für street bad
akteure eine prima möglichkeit um
feedback zu bekommen
auf der straße entferne ich mich vom
tatort sobald ich meine zettel
angebracht habe deshalb habe ich nie die
möglichkeit zu sehen wie die menschen
reagieren derweil der hype um die
straßenkunst fragen aufwirft wem gehört
streetart darf ein galerist damit geld
verdienen darf er ein illegal
angebrachtes kunstwerk von der wand
nehmen den hype and love banksy 2013 mit
dieser aktion
er lässt seine bilder von einem
straßenhändler verkaufen für 60 dollar
einen bruchteil des marktwertes
niemand nimmt notiz tageseinnahmen 420
dollar und einige ahnungslose passanten
gehen mit einem echten banksy nach hause
wir sind zurück kam street art festival
in chur